okay I guess I'm live okay I'm trying to
get organized here and I'm going to have
my iPad on where I will see the area
okay in order because just to go back
down here okay we're just about ready to
go what I'm going to do is so that I can
see the questions as they show up I am
going to have the video up on iPad and
yes will you upload boy there's so many
questions I'm not sure this is a good
idea anyway I'm gonna start now or no I
got a mouth area okay today I want to
talk first of all ahead the first half
of my week is Arabic so I'm in the
Arabic part of my week so I'm gonna talk
a bit about Arabic I'm gonna talk a bit
about tutors and getting more out of our
tutors and a little bit about how to
customize your whole language learning
experience which i think is very
important
traditionally we go to our classroom
we're passive the teacher comes in with
whatever they're going to teach a
curriculum the plan for the day the
teachers in charge and we are basically
the not the victim but we are the
targets Osby and I think in the modern
world where there are so many resources
and so many so much good content so many
grammar sources
where it's so attractive and and
possible to learn languages we have to
be more proactive and that's therefore
true and how we interact with our tutor
and it's true generally in how we
approach our language learning and so
that's what I'm gonna talk about here
today but with an emphasis on the role
of the tutor and how important the tutor
is by the way for this Zorn who's
helping me he's in Serbia with the
questions and the idea was that I would
have the video on on my iPad and see all
the questions but there's such a stream
of comments that that's not going to
work so I'm gonna leave it to Zoran and
to pick out of this stream of comments
those questions that he thinks are
particularly interesting and feed them
to me via slack because this other
approach is not going to work okay but
you know all of this stuff we're
exploring your learning so this is not a
practical solution all right so I want
to first of all talk about customizing
our language learning experience with
specific reference to how we interact
with tutors and with that I am going to
share my screen with you so screen share
here and screen share and that's desktop
2 and Start screen share all right so
hopefully now everyone can see my screen
yeah so and I'm gonna turn this off
because this is delayed let's see I hope
everyone can see the screen hello
no if I look at the oh here we are ok so
the time to turn this thing off because
it's just too confusing to be seeing
something else that's on delay or
whatever so ok and so hopefully Zoran
will push questions to me on the 90 day
challenge thread as
all right so I'm at my where I like to
be for language learning which is
obviously linked and we are going to
talk about tutors but before we get to
tutors and how they best interact with
tutors I want to point out how important
it is to be aware that we can customize
what we're doing first of all let us go
and so I'm gonna point out some things
about link that some of you may be aware
of and others may not be aware of so
first of all to see you can get a sense
of what we've been doing we go to the
profile page and so if I look at my
Arabic I can see my activities for the
last seven days and you'll see that
typically I was active then I'm not
active and then I'm active because
that's what I'm doing right now I'm
going part of the week in Arabic party
week in Farsi so if I showed my Farsi or
Persian profile it would be the mirror
opposite of my Arabic profile but I can
also look at when I first started with
Arabic and so I will see that if I look
at say non words accumulating known
words which is to me a very important
milestone like I am driven if we talk
about customizing our language learning
experience I am driven by the desire to
increase my own words total because I
know from experience that when I have
enough words ten thousand fifteen
thousand words
I'm able to understand content that's
interesting I'm able to understand it
when I hear it and when I read it and
when I get to that stage then I can
really you know develop in the language
while you know listening to and reading
content that's interesting to me so I'm
learning things while improving my
language and I know that at my president
level of 7,200 words in Arabic I'm far
from being there although this morning I
was doing an article from Al Jazeera and
I saw myself understanding much more
than I did before I see also that my
activity when it comes to non words has
been sporadic it certainly from August
to
ooh October I didn't do too much summer
family visiting with us in Vancouver
from London whatever then I picked it up
just prior to my visit to Morocco and
then it's fallen off of it that would be
the situation with known words if I look
at listening again it follows a similar
pattern and I was very active earlier on
have been less active recently yet it is
all accumulative and it's important to
remember that everything that we do even
if we slack and off at certain times we
are always accumulating experience and
therefore we are accumulating ability so
to speak in the language so what I'm
gonna do by the way next time is I'm
gonna show you my history on all the
different languages that I have learned
Russian check Korea and so forth and
you'll see how you know this activity
can be sporadic but it is all cumulative
you don't lose anything now if I go back
to say the lessons area and I just want
to point out that you can customize a
number of things first of all you don't
have to land
I used to land on my library all the
time and but really I wanted to land on
the last lesson and I was studying my
lessons so if you go into the settings
you can set first of all in your face
language and and you know a number of
other things if you want to see the
lesson feed or don't want to see it you
can also customize the reader setting so
for example I turned off the automatic
that's the speech Oh home settings by
the way where was it I can't remember
where I found that review settings
reader settings I don't know where I
found page size home settings nice
review says no home settings interface
language Oh default tab here it is
default tab if you don't want to land on
the library every time
you can choose where you can you can
land on the playlist you can land on the
vocabulary so I found it better to land
on my lessons so I changed my sentence
so I just want to point out that every
little thing that you do to customize
your learning to make it work for you is
is going to be powerful now similarly
when it comes to how you interact with
your tutor so I have typically not used
online tutors that much I as you know
I'm very much Pro input based learning
however with Arabella the recent
language is Arabic and farsi in
particular I have tended to work more
with online tutors and so I want to talk
a little bit about that first of all you
want to choose a tutor that that has you
know that is that works for you so if we
go to the tutor page you know I did a
number of lessons with Ibrahim Mustapha
from Egypt I highly recommend him he's
an excellent tutor however the timing
doesn't work he is his timing that works
for him is in the afternoon well I can
force myself to be there in the
afternoon but in fact when my wife and I
are here in Palm Springs you know we're
doing other things in the afternoon so I
like to study in the morning in the
evening so I need tutors who are
available when it's most convenient for
me and so I'm not forcing myself to you
know to do something that I know I can't
maintain so for that reason I moved away
from I have had lessons with JQH
delightful tutor from originally from
Palestine from Bethlehem but who lives
in Kuwait and holidays in Spain and but
recently I've tried to connect with her
and I didn't get any confirmation back
so now I have been working with Dalia
who I am going to be talking to at 11:00
and she is excellent and she because
another thing that I think is very
important obviously a high quality can
is important she's very encouraging and
we've started you know III will insist
from now on that any tutor I work with
has to give me a decent report with lots
of words and phrases that I've struggled
with and a recording this really makes
the whole session you know that much
more valuable because I can review them
again and again and I'll show you how I
do that and I can listen to them again
and again and of course when we're with
the tutor and even the decision on how
much time do you spend with you know
online tutors as opposed to how much
time do you spend forging ahead in the
language reading listening I mean this
is again where you have to customize it
I've often said that you know in
language learning you know it's it's
novelty and repetition and so the
repetition sort of consolidates what you
have learned and the the novelty is is
the brain wants something new fresh
interesting so you kind of combine the
two when I'm having a discussion with my
tutor we are largely consolidating
things that I have already learned
because I have to be able to use words
that I have new words crop up so there's
that degree of novelty but it's mainly a
matter of of consolidation and on links
they when I show you my statistics in
different languages you'll see that in
some languages you can say ahead saving
new words I mean if you know Spanish in
you're learning Italian you can acquire
the new words very very quickly not
necessarily well enough to use them but
certainly well enough to recognize them
so less consolidation is needed but in
the case of Arabic and Persian I need a
lot of consolidation because it's just
so difficult to remember the words I
have no real you know I need to get a
better sense of how the language
functions and so therefore I end up
spending more time with tutors but one
other thing that I'm doing in Arabic
which I did a little bit in Farsi
is reading with the tutor reading with
the tutor helps me and I'll give you a
demonstration for example in this lesson
here as easy Abu Saleh al-fulani yeah
yeah time
Yatta Yatta shoe candidate but yet I'm
sure she she would help me with that
pronunciation Lisa
Bellavia Ellicott's okay the first
Palestinian candidate for mayor of
Jerusalem you'll see him there he uses a
lot of Levantine Arabic in mixed in with
his Standard Arabic so in reading this
together with Dalia words that had been
I couldn't find them in the dictionary I
didn't understand what was going on she
was able to explain that so reading with
her may enable me to read better the
disadvantages that if we spend the hour
reading and then I don't get a lot of
new words in the report so you know this
is where you have to I was gonna show
you some examples let's see here okay
okay so where does Azizi speak here
Aziz okay okay let's go back one more
let's see
mmm Zizi I was okay so in in Newfie
suburban but there is an area where he
uses the roof roof which means so far so
far you know well is roof and he's got
this um like he has a number of nut who
becomes agna toaster here we are roof
the roof Hilton
so he uses a lot of words that come out
of Levantine Arabic apparently so that
was the helpful to me
so so I have options now in dealing with
my tutor I can say we want to read
that's gonna help my reading so I'm
investing in improving my ability to
read in the language so that when I'm
reading on my own I do better however
the downside is that I will get fewer
words in my report because the report
consists of words and phrases that I
struggle to use so but I do want to
invest some in that at other times I
want to invest more in a free-flowing
conversation on subjects of interest to
me so that'll generate some suggestions
of vocabulary that then I can study this
is helping me create you know relevant
input because I still do I'm still very
much a believer that input is what
teaches you the language but you want to
generate either find or generate
relevant input and so even my
interaction with my tutor is is largely
an input oriented activity one other
thing that's very important in in
interacting with the tutor is that if
we're learning on our own
obviously motivation is tremendously
important and the tutor has a vital role
in motivating the learner and so for
example when I think of the fact that
I'm going to be talking to Dalia
of course I'm very motivated I want to
show her that I've improved that I I
learned something from the last time of
course very often I don't improve and I
make the same mistakes and and when I
review my when I review my let's go and
have a look at that when I review my so
you can I can look at my lesson Siri
lessons or courses so let's go to
courses go go faster conversation
reports and I can go in and see all of
my conversation reports going back
to August and when I do that I see that
I make the same mistakes over and over
again that's perfectly normal
but still we are motivated we are
motivated to to improve to show our
tutor that we are doing them so to that
extent the tutor is also an important
motivate some of us require more
external motivation some require less so
that's another sort of element that goes
into you know customizing your learning
activity customizing your interactions
with the tutor
also if the tutor is reluctant to
provide a recording of the report or
gives you a very short report I have no
trouble asking the tutor because the
tutor you're only paying for an hour and
very often the tutor has another hour
schedule and so I've said look I'll end
the conversation 10 minutes early but
please I want you to give me a decent
report and to record it Symbian mp3 file
of course the the report that we get
it's it's very easy to think because you
know if you open any of these let's go
to the most recent one here from Dalia
if we open the report oh this is Artyom
I wanted to show you how we receive it
but it comes as you see with audio
recordings but if I look at the tutor
section and if I look at my activities
and I will see this a conversation
report from Rana in your report so it
comes this way with the audio attached
and I just import it and then I have a
lessons of stuff so that's kind of
convenient when it comes to you know
interacting with your tutor so I don't
want to cover too much material or
everyone will get confused I just wanted
to cover some of the things that I do
our link is some of the ways that I've
customized my learning but I would
interested in anybody's comments and
maybe I will go back to the video and
because I'm not getting any questions
from Zora and let me just see here no no
I have to try and find it and let's see
no okay
but as I say if you have questions let
me know and I will try to pop up that
YouTube video and see if I can pick out
some questions from the list here okay
okay let's go to the very top what
language did you enjoy learning the most
I enjoy learning all my high wages it's
amazing I'm very much enjoying Arabic
and Persian
I enjoy Greek I enjoy Korean I enjoy all
of the languages learn Finnish sorry
can't see any video how did you get a
high an old word count on link do you
review you or it's often or just consume
more content the word count alright this
is a very important point most of the
words that i acquire on link i acquire
incidentally in other words after a
while if i see particularly in languages
where there two or three or four forms
of a particular word or words often have
you know similar components but mean
slightly different things and we don't
feel we need to look them up but some I
do deliberately move to known in other
words they have shown up as yellow links
so often that now when I look at them
you know I just I know them now I've
moved it from from status for the status
3 the status to and and now I know so
you know and and a small number get
there get there because I've gone
through reviewing them I do reviews but
that would not
count for annastolz
pre sharing that would not account for
the the words that I have learned a very
small part of it
so hey again as you know the trick in
order to increase your word count is to
do a lot of reading new stuff rereading
old stuff obviously words that you have
encountered in your reading and have
converted from blue to yellow
those yellow words show up again and
again and again and and it's I find it
very helpful to know that this is a word
that I've seen before so it's not
completely new to me even though I don't
know what it means and then I have I
might even have refined the meaning
because it might be several possible
hints I've selected one that I think is
relevant so the second time I look it up
I have a more irrelevant hint there and
that's the process higher known word
count is simply a matter of being active
in fact I think what's important with
our statistics that link is that they
measure your level of activity and if
you are active if you are reading and
listening and encountering work birds in
different contexts and reviewing them
and doing all these things you will
improve so the best measure in a way
that most meaningful milestones are all
of these statistics because trying to
evaluate how much you have improved
based on some subjective criteria is
much more difficult okay how are you
managing to learn more than four at once
okay I don't learn for it once I at the
present time I'm learning to Arabic and
Persian but I tried that I worked on
Greek because we went to Crete so and
and the other thing that I think is
important and and when you saw those
statistics of where I've been very
active saying Arabic and less active or
more active and pertinent less active
whatever I feel that I put into a
language in terms of my activity is
never lost
all right it's it's there and it can be
reactivated
but right now I'm dealing with - do you
prefer to read paper books or online
books okay if I know the words I prefer
to read paper books however
if there are even more than a few
percent like on a different page if
there are three or four words that I
don't know then I prefer to read at
linked actually because I can work them
up because they go from blue to yellow I
mean looking a word up doesn't mean
you've learned it very often you've
forgotten the meaning soon after you've
looked it up so it's not just a matter
of looking it up it's a matter of of
getting it into the stream of words that
will eventually become words that I can
least understand and eventually use I'm
going to let that ring so you know there
comes a point where I can read it and I
will sometimes read paper books and just
ignore the words that I don't know
because it is more comfortable to read a
paper ball so I in Czech tour in Polish
I would read in hate on paper and just
let the words that I don't know go by me
how do you manage your time between them
do you not feel like you're progressing
slowly we always feel that we're
progressing slowly in the language
oh that question was not directed to me
it was the right to the cells okay
you know I have questions here in Arabic
but I'm just not good enough on the fly
to read them okay where are my Spanish
learners at I'm at university I have
four like pieces on my degree okay so
that's where that came from
alright you're not even there so people
are talking to each other but ah
so people talking to each other that's
good that's good I'm just trying to make
sure that there aren't any questions to
me that Steve have you ever challenged
with a tutor in only target language
it's pretty easy to have the tutor has a
system it's great for for unit so that I
only talk to my tutor in the target
language I discourage the tutor from
using English occasionally English comes
up but mostly my was Ibrahim Mustafa
didn't speaking well he's talking mister
we didn't speak English and the good
tutors in Farsi or inversion they just
explained it over and over again in in
the target
that's why I don't like to get started
with a tutor until I at least have some
vocabulary and some comprehension
ability so yeah I don't start from
scratch for the tooth I think that's a
rather poor use of the tutors time and
of your money
what dialect of Arabic I am learning
standard Arabic we do have some
Levantine Arabic and Egyptian Arabic
content on length at times I sort of am
tempted to try to get in there but then
I realize that I still got a long way to
go to get my standard Arabic I want to
get Standard Arabic because there's so
much content out there um yeah radio
podcast newspaper articles and I am
convinced that if at any point I wanted
to focus in on Levantine or Egyptian
Arabic that the better might push our
Standard Arabic the easier I will find
it to get into these more specific
versions of Arabic so okay now I
download the app link but it's very
expensive for me
it's too bad we also have expenses we
have programmers and other personnel
when I use the built-in stories on
LinkedIn highlight sections of text but
when I import a story it will only do
single words okay this is a specific
technical issue I don't know the answer
Luke Connor if you would it ID I will
try to call up button perhaps you could
say if you could comment on our forum
other people may or may not be
experiencing this that would be very
helpful for us okay can you give me link
I don't understand that
can you give me thick I had my first
conversation talked about two weeks and
it did very well
good how do you focus when you're
listening to many stories I find it off
and gets repetitive and boring and I end
up reading instead you're sure I mean I
am very motivated you first of all you
can't just do the mini stories but at an
early stage in the language that's kind
of all I'm able to do and I am very
motivated to get a sense of the
structures of phrasing in the mini
stories are focused on the most
invert and I believe that if you can do
very well with the verbs tenses and how
they're used
give take think need want that that
really helps you get you know a leg up
on the language so I can take it but I
can see where some people would find
find it boring that's why you need to
get a other material as well and it also
depends on your level where I almost
just heaves every now phone could just
he's not had that funny tell you huh
maybe if your mother focus is I'm a
block terrifically give your mother come
home ha ha ha ha
Bob so he's making progress in his
Italian but he is kind of blocked when
he goes to speak ok you have to the only
way you can be block yourself is to
speak more but I find that if I do a lot
of listening and reading and then in
this regard I find the mini stories very
helpful because they they give you
momentum they give you sort of basic
phrases around the the most important
verbs so you have these phrases bouncing
around in your brain and then when you
want to speak you just saw them out
there don't worry about getting things
right or wrong or just let it go out a
get out and you'll hear the way the
other person speech and as through this
process you'll gradually get unblocked
but it's difficult I'm not pretending
that you can just get up there and start
speaking right away ah
like I'm Friday ok Indonesia and they're
talking to each other when starting it
did better to repeat the lesson that
link or move through a lot of lessons
that repeat later on
I repeat later on so again yeah nowadays
I start with many stories edited in
Arabic version and stuff agree so I'll
go one two three four five back to one
so I might listen to the one two three
four times read it two three four times
still not really get it it certainly
don't remember the words
I'm tired of the story I go to story too
I do the same I worked my way up ten
story five and then I go back to Story
one again and I go one two three four
five and then the some point I add six
and I go back and seven and pretty
soon I'm up to 1015 buddy and therefore
if I look at my playlist I'll see that I
listened the story 150 times sorry 245
times and by the time I met story 15 I
only listened to that 15 times so here
we have gender steel metal as min Poland
Latham a general search team Italian
Italian American on the Kiska massive
yeah well what you know he also bought a
signal foreigner I see meal I've haven't
done a scale-free English I have done
assuming for Russian good content Korean
not so good Arabic Persian there's you
know it's not enough it's a bit it's not
gonna teach you the language well a
similar second system avec mirada de te
voir la joie de la maison emphasis a
casino for beaucoup beaucoup the
continent took no service original don't
assume especially on my evo equity
bokuto special difficult for vocally
emotionally balanced Assoc see the
deserve to Mecca APA which it isn't
ok here did you forget words that you're
Marcus learn yes of course
and then you link them again ok so
number people get bored with many
stories many stories are starter
material and also a place where you go
back to occasionally to exercise to
practice in the basic structures of the
language I find now say an Arabic or
Persian I can go back to the many
stories do two or three and then I'm out
of there again because it's too boring
but when I got started I could you know
I would totally overdose on the many
stories yes I forget words that I've
learned and
thank them again yes always what
motivated you to learn Arabic okay
Arabic you know I mean I like to learn
languages that are spoken by a lot of
people that have a lot of history it's
part of my sort of discovering the world
you know initially I so my wife and I
went to Crete we went to Israel we went
to Jordan to dr. Wow
so I learned Greek because I was gonna
be on the island of Crete and I was able
to use it and and it's fun that I can
now read Greek and of course my Greek is
kind of ability to speak is declined
somewhat but it's there and I can go
back to it I tried to learn Hebrew but I
wasn't there very long and then I said
to myself look there's 10 million people
who speak Hebrew there's 3 400 million
people who speak Arabic so I was
motivated to learn Arabic and and now
that I'm into Arabic and Persian and I'm
gonna do Turkish and you realize that
the extent to which these three
languages have interacted and the
civilization that culture built around
that part of the world it's all
fascinating it's all a part of
discovering the world so yeah that's why
I'm interested in Arabic okay here's
that's interesting Alex shaft tells me
that Iraqi dialect is closer to Standard
Arabic than other dialects that's fine I
will you know get there one day
have I become with listening skills what
can I do to find a solution for my
problem listening is key listening is
the corner ability what you do is you
have to listen a lot whenever you listen
to you should try to read so that you
have a better chance of understanding
the second time you listen and then read
again and listen the third time and you
just gradually you have to consider your
brain there's something that has to be
trained in the listening and if you're
just listening to noise and you just
don't understand anything I think that's
it's gonna take a long time to get there
so make sure you have a transcript for
what you're listening to and do a lot of
listening listen everywhere you can a
man said that many many times I listen
when I do house chores
listen when I exercise I listen in the
car and then I spent some time reading
while I listen to so that I have a
chance of my understanding more of it
the next time okay I wanted for my time
but no secret well do a lot of listening
I Italian there's so much wonderful
content out there to listen to and then
hopefully you'll find an opportunity to
use it now aligned is 360 is one hour a
day enough to learn language one hour a
day is better than fifty minutes a day
so I think one hour a day is a good
number I did that for a long time with
Russian right now I'm probably doing two
hours a day in the morning in the
evening but it's it's better than
nothing okay I am Brazilian right so
hard for me to learn English I'm
assuming actually the you speak English
quite well another thing is people
shouldn't be so hard on themselves
there's no my English is no good but
your English son is undoubtedly better
than it was six months ago a year ago or
before you ever learned any English so
we have to kind of recognize that we are
progressing even though very difficult
sometimes to get a real feel network
progressing
I prefer reading or listening so my
listening is like being young okay
that's a choice I talked about
customizing our learning experience at
some point you know try listening at
times when you can't read you can't read
while driving the car or you know there
are times when it's not convenient to
read but you can listen do you have a
set routine every day or just listen to
read whenever oh sorry I missed from my
question is is it advisable to use the
communicative method with Romance
languages and Asian languages I don't
know what the communicative method is I
think the learning system is not so much
dependent on whether it's Romance
languages or Asian languages we you know
if we're English speakers will progress
more quickly in Romance languages
because there's a lot of common
vocabulary in Asian language learning
Arabic just gonna take a little bit
longer you might spend more time you
know for example in many stories in the
sort of simple repetitive stuff to get a
better hold of the language whereas if
we're going into Spanish we can progress
very
into offensive content I don't know what
the communicative method is my method is
lots of listening and read as a sort of
foundation from which to start speaking
except do you have per set routine well
I try to you know early in the morning
and sometimes after breakfast and in the
evening after dinner
those are my study times in terms of
like working with link-up iPad reading
and reviewing words and stuff the
listening takes place during the day if
I'm on my bicycle if I'm working around
the house you know whatever I managed to
scrape together 15 minutes here 20
minutes there at least an hour or
listening plus the more deliberate
stepping time ah do you have acidity can
you share a good podcast website in
Russian with text to use of link all
right yeah a lot of people in Russia
don't like chemistry
it's a radio station echo echo of Moscow
you can look it up but it has a
tremendous advantage in that it has
every day it has interviews where you
have you can download the audio and you
can also find download the text so you
can import all of that into the link in
fact we obtain permission from echo must
be to use their material at link and we
have uploaded quite a bit of their
material at link and you have to be a
little careful that there must be a I
think the person who runs it venediktov
he kind of sees this as a platform for
everything on anything so you have a lot
of people who are critical of the
government of mr. Putin you have the
extreme nationalists you got the
materialistic ah you got everything on
there and there is a tendency for people
to say things that aren't necessarily
verifiable so you don't have to worry
too much about that content per se in
terms of it whether it's true or you
believe it or you don't believe it but
as a source of audio with detect
material very lively hemispheres is
phenomenal in my opinion my visit
advisable that's not okay yeah we go way
to Russia yes
what would be your approach alert lands
you are not passionate about and you
have to learn it for example for work
okay that's a good question
my advice there is there is an
expression in French let the key via on
mahjong so the appetite comes with the
IDI so you have to force yourself if you
have to learn line with her work you
have to begin by forcing yourself
develop some habits look for things of
interest is if music is an artist at
history find stuffing find a person you
like find something about it you don't
have to like the whole language the
whole culture every representative of
that culture you have to find something
that you can like and so I would make an
effort to do that okay and you know say
oh I got there hi Steve you don't record
yourself speaking and listening back to
it you mentioned doing it in your book
in your early days it language yeah I
don't do that now I did do it for French
and for Mandarin it's just something
I've stopped doing again I talked about
customizing your language learning
experience if you like doing that I
think it can be helpful I don't worry so
much about my pronunciation now so do
that if you enjoy doing it I don't think
it's necessary and don't do it often it
would be my advice as well there are a
number of things that sound like a good
idea we do them once or twice and then
we don't find them either useful or fun
and so we stopped doing it and would you
look at my link stats and advise you
know it's difficult for me to do you
know what I will I will talk about Linux
test on Wednesday in different languages
and maybe we can look at different
people's links test somehow and talk
about them how many hours approximate
you should one study per day if they
wanted to teach see why I'm in Chinese
within three years hmm difficult to say
I mean as many hours as you can devote
to it but I think if you're looking at
three years
you know when I learned Chinese
basically in a year and I was going out
at six seven hours a day so I think if
you did two or three hours a day you
should be able to achieve c1 in three
years
thank you for your answer see if I'd
love to get advice to my links that I
see that will do that we'll deal with
that on on Wednesday that's more than a
minute just switch it values a gallon
premiered on Liske Francis nearly
Chileans are using you know here's Ava
asking you know if it's possible to
learn two languages at the same time for
someone who has not studied foreign
languages I get and do it at that stage
I'm now going to languages at the same
time I think the more languages you
learn the better you get
so my advice probably would be to focus
on one it does not just cos at IVA when
no such as Yahoo jolly very is a key
part of my Russians can be very rusty
and rainy and very years Akita no cara
de manana cava mm open then is a genom
years ago yeah as I said a touchless na
na music yeah
what if it would love us okay rusty
since I've amazing progress my English I
decided to excel in French shall I
consider in French to English or is it
better stick to my l1 it depends on how
good your English is but to judge from
what you've written here
your English is extremely good and I
think I would do it through the English
but there's some extent that you find
useful content explanations of grammar
or whatever that's based in Russian I
would use both like I had used I have
used French and English to learn like
right now for my Arabic I bought a
number of resources in French so I
really don't think it matters but I have
the impression
looking at your English that you would
be great capable of doing it in English
so why not do it uh what sitter in
Arabic in Arab is Arabic only the
language can you speak Mandarin yes I
can speak Mandarin Arabic is the
language Arab is the sort of ethnic
group at this level do you find person
easier than Arabic much easier much
easier version is much easier than
Arabic it's easier to read the writing
is more you know the relationship
between what's written and what's
pronounced is much closer than in Arabic
the grammatical structure features that
I'm familiar with from other European
languages Persian is an indo-european
language it's much easier that's not to
say that it's nicer more fun or anything
else it's just easier what does the
hardest language you have learned they
are hard in different ways but I mean
Chinese is hard because of having to
learn the characters Arabic is hard
because of the writing system and some
of the grammatical features you know
japanese has this whole politeness love
so languages are difficult in different
ways I don't even worry about it I just
go ahead and learn if it is it easier to
learn Chinese if you know korean easier
than depends on your native languages
but I would say that yes because a lot
of 50% of the vocabulary in Korean is of
Chinese order the structure of Korean is
is if anything I would say the structure
of English is closer to the structure of
Chinese by vocabulary in China in Korea
a lot of the Chinese character Cavalieri
would be recognizable okay then hello
sir how do you determine when you are
ready to move on to a different language
when I feel like it that's all like I'm
gonna be going to Ukraine second half of
May so the end of this three-month
period I'm going to try to improve you
know kind of revive a bit my my Russian
and Ukrainian thereafter I'm going to
work a little bit on Korean oh yeah I'm
retired I do what I want so
I feel I did how do you divide up a
typical study hour in terms of what you
do listening reading puck does linking
etcetera do you have a common template
there's no common template obviously I
have to put a certain amount of effort
into finding content like purging online
for example or you know al Jazeera or
calls bad gas podcast I'm investing
enough into the sort of automatic
transcription of these podcasts so
there's a certain amount of territory
work but then typically first thing in
the morning I read and then I have to
decide if I'm going to read old stuff
and where there are no blue words where
I'm sort of refreshing and trying to get
a better grasp on the language listen to
it or if I'm gonna forge ahead into new
stuff difficult stuff and then after the
reading that I do in the morning then
that prepares me for my term listening
activity during the day whenever I have
the opportunity but once I sit down to
do my reading on my iPad I'll stay there
for an hour but I might jump around I
might review some of my previous
conversation reports and then spend
another half-hour so forging ahead in
the latest transcribed podcast from Al
Jazeera and then I might be one or two
many stories okay then I go off and I
spend you know when I clean up but when
I clean up after dinner or whatever I'm
gonna be listening for working out from
the gym so there's no plan per se I know
this is tough to answer because you've
constantly improved but assuming all
languages are equally interesting which
do you think would be the hardest for
most people I have no idea I have no
idea I think Japanese might be more
difficult than Arabic but I had no real
you know information to base this on how
did you manage to learn Korean when the
words have so many definitions yes hurry
in and that regard is very difficult the
dictionary it's the language where I
found the dictionaries least helpful and
I have neighbor and I have other green
dictionaries and it's just a matter of
exposing yourself to enough content
after a while you see certain words in
certain contexts and you start to get a
sense of what the words mean and that's
why I add link we don't call the meaning
that you find in the dictionary a
definition it's only a hint and in
Korean very often the dictionary
definition is less of them even less of
a definition it's just a hint and you
just have to be into enough content that
you start to see how these words are you
and and I constantly have to remind
myself that I have a better sense of
three and now a Korean than I had six
months ago over two years ago so we
always do improve even if we don't
necessarily have a great sense of that
improvement what language did you plan
to learn that you picture it well right
now I am I I'm in my sort of Arabic
Persian Turkish so the next one would be
Turkish thereafter I might move into the
South Asian languages time will tell how
many languages how many know where do
you think it will take to be fluent in
Korean or excuse me in Chinese remember
that the known word total is like an
indicator it's an indicator of your
level of activity so it's not to say
that you absolutely need X number of non
words to be fluent but in terms of how
much activity say a link would be
necessary to become fluent III I still
think it's a surprisingly high number
it's like 30 40 50 thousand words that's
what I found in all languages it doesn't
matter
Korean check Russian you got to get up
to that fifty thousand on the way we
count words don't think so
it's a long road but hopefully it can be
interesting for you okay thank you mr.
Steve Francie McPherson no problem
and do you tell your tutor what to do
yes I do I tell my tutor that what to do
but I also like to I like a tutor who is
able to ask me questions who it says you
know a self-starter as well I don't want
to be sick because it's difficult for me
to initiate the conversation and so the
best tutors you give them an indication
of what you'd like to do what you like
to talk about you
report you want a recording and then
they engage you with interesting
questions and when you struggle they
supply you know some wording in the
language and and so forth any tips if
you want to get proficient enough at a
language to do some translating work in
the future specifically as a native
German talking about translating
Japanese well I just think that you know
listening reading I mean reading and
words you need vocabulary you need
structure you need to see how the
language works so that when you become a
translator it's it's natural to you so
you have to develop the sort of good
instinct in the language and I have with
my Japanese men in situations where I'm
interpreting spontaneously and you just
know what it means when you hear it you
know what it means or when you have to
transfer translate into that language
you just know instinctively how that is
translated to get to that level requires
a lot of exposure to the language of
course with reference to grammar as
required when you're curious about
structure you're hesitant you don't know
for sure you look it up you forget but
the main thing is that some exposure to
the language no wonder has Steve about
his favorite Arabic textbook and what is
the type of textbook or resort he wishes
existed for learning Arabic okay I
haven't found a good textbook per se I
enjoy I enjoy our Arabic many stories I
think I enjoy going through my
conversation reports from my tutor
what I would really wish existed right
now so I have done the many stories in
Arabic and I can go to al-jazeera
and read a newspaper article and listen
to the podcast what as missing is
something in between and personally I'm
not that interested in the Quran I'm not
in not interested in religion period as
Cemile has these stories about some of
the pre-islamic some guy with the sword
and the poet knowledge is too deep I
can't handle that stuff I'm not that
it's not that relevant to me what would
be great to have is textbooks in Arabic
with audio on the history of Arabic
countries prius land post islam
geography current events slightly
simplified followed with some discussion
where the vocabulary is repeated a lot
that would be to me phenomenal that's
sort of taking me from my certain early
stages in arabic to where i can then
access genuine authentic material it
doesn't require a lot of grammatical
explanation the on grammatical note
might be useful if I take a cinema as an
example there's too much explanation so
you go to the explanation it doesn't
tell you anything that you haven't
already noticed in the language we can
over explain I think it's much better to
have a reference area where you can go
and look up certain things and maybe it
should be made easier to get to relevant
explanations when you need them rather
than having as an essay mail you know
you got if you start eating all our
explanations you spend your whole time
reading the explanation and you're
distracted from that content per se okay
why have you chosen MSA modern Standard
Arabic rather than a dialect would you
consider learning the Tunisian dialect
I chosen MSA because it is the standard
I can't learn Tunisia and Moroccan
eleventeen Syrian Jordan whatever Gulf I
learned the standard and then if I were
to go on a trip to Tanisha of course I
would try to learn the Tunisian dialect
but I am quite happy with modern
Standard Arabic because there's lots of
resources available in it why can't I
customize Enki I don't find anything bah
bah bah I don't use manky so I can't
speak I looking for a Greek resource
yeah I mean you can have a look at what
we do at link there are some resources
there I was unable to find a podcast in
Greek with transcript I found a podcast
about the building of the Acropolis I
paid to have some of those transcribe
that's expensive
not often I discovered this
automatic transcription service and just
Google automatic transcription and
you'll find it and that brings the cost
down so it's a matter like I did you
have to Google to find your Greek
podcast and then you have to try to find
this transcription service if you're
prepared to spend twenty thirty dollars
a month will you be able to partner with
publishers to get novels and audio for
sale free link we are approaching them
we're trying those people are very
difficult to deal with they don't follow
up so we'll see but we're trying okay
510 whatever okay what time - Kenia
Monge that means no stress - link I know
people have done so I did that with
Russian I am sure the only trouble with
with obviously with Japanese or Chinese
is that you have to learn the characters
on your own yes learn characters by hand
I think it's helpful blah blah blah
thank you mother since you are fluent in
a lot of lines like to ask in Europe and
you wanna sign the language it will be
more important in the future I think
there will be the increasing role for
regional languages like Spanish Russian
Arabic that's languages are spoken in a
lot of countries and that that might be
a counterweight to the importance of
English thank you for answering my
questions about our limitations and we
appreciate answers publishing house
choice way has superb line text books
for men and gentlemen if you check it
out ok I'll look it up not sure if I can
share TVs nuts in here but he is able to
provide kind of Jerusalem talk about ok
I would love to have that Steve at link
comm send me an email we'd love to
follow up particularly we can partner
red link Steve at link
aligned GQ huh you think it's useful to
keep read listening to other material if
here are comprehending it completely and
without any difficulty well if there are
structures that you still struggle with
and this material as the instructors and
you're noticing them I think that's
useful I sometimes do that both of you
will have indicated across it will
prolong the concern is that are among
the received over two thousand eight
apprecia electron should we be teaching
foreign languages and an earlier a this
is from Quebec
um yes in fact what I would like to see
in schools is that kids get exposed to
more languages in Canada we tend to have
this fixation with the official
languages if you're in French if you're
a French language school you learn
English if you're an English language
school you're in French I think we
should expose young people to a variety
of languages not necessarily with the
intention of getting them to speak but
getting them exposed and get developing
some degree of comprehension and I think
this will make their brains more
flexible and at a later stage if they
become very motivated they'll have an
easier time learning languages so
exposed young people to more languages
and the argument that schools always is
we don't have a qualified teacher well
there's so many resources available on
the internet that need matter how many
words do people converse wide and read
limits as I said 30 40 50 thousand words
it's a high it's a high number blah blah
blah I'm also learning French as what
reserves do you have on link to help you
expose your difference where can you
expect it at link you can choose a
filter in our library and you can you
know look for content that's in
québécois or in the accent from Quebec I
don't think they have a lot of such
material if there's interest we can try
to find more if there are some cubic why
don't wanna help us create some content
talk to your friends transcribed at it
and put it in our library that will
create more material because I know
there is a demand for people who are
going to be working pro back are living
in Quebec for such material do you
sometimes have problems with confusing
languages oh sure
always yeah I mean speaking foreign
languages is a matter of confusion is a
matter of being less you know making
mistakes being less fluent than you are
in your own language it comes with the
territory and at that I'm gonna cut it
off thank you very much bye for now